If there could be a dream like project
or a dream opportunity.
Right? The reunion of or the
collaboration between all of the
artists that I've had the privilege to
work with any of these things, have any
of these things dead or alive?
I mean, damn. Wow.
I'm going to say both.
If you could combine it.
If you could pick your dream, your
dream work.
This is my dream work project.
My dream work project attached to
music. And this right here.
Oh, my God. If I had the opportunity to
do, what would that be for you, man?
That's man.
You should have started this
mother****ing interview with that one.
That's a great one. Yeah.
Why would I start it with that?
We're getting close to the end.
You start to get a big bangers at the
end.
Yeah. It's going to sound really weird,
you know? Curtis Mayfield.
Marvin Gaye. Wow.
Kurt Cobain. Jimi Hendrix.
Freddie Mercury.
Music buff.
Yeah, I mean, I can go on.
Barry White. Wow.
Isaac Hayes. Led Zeppelin.
Well, yeah.
Wow. So, you know, those are most of my
heroes. And of course, this is a really
f***ing crazy story.
Stevie Wonder, there's-- There's a
couple of times in my career where I
f***ing. Bowed out and just.
I was going to ask you that next. Who,
who did you have the opportunity to
work with? And he was like, No, I
didn't. That you regret and that you
should have worked with. But I don't
want to throw your story off.
No, but yeah, that's a good segway.
Prince. Michael Jackson.
You bowed out from working with them?
Yeah. Both of.
Them? Yeah.
You didn't work with both Prince and
Michael Jackson? Yeah.
Was it like a demo tape or something?
Nah, they just asked me to work with
them and just like, What the f*** am I
going to do with them? What?
Yeah, that happened.
What?
Yeah.
Was there, like.
What the f*** am I going to do in the
studio with them? Those are my f***ing
heroes, man. You know you're doctor.
Dre. Stop.
You're doctor f***ing Dre.
What do you mean?
Most recently Stevie Wonder.
So I'm working on an album with Marcia
Ambrosia. Right? Ah she's so talented.
She's amazing. And we did some music, a
song using Stevie Wonder's music, and
he had to clear it. And he called me up
like, Yo, Jay. For some reason, Stevie
Wonder calls you, like, super early in
the morning. Like six, seven in the
morning or some shit. I'm like this
because you can't see the time like.
The f***, right?
So true story.
It's like I don't like the lyrics.
I don't like the lyrics. Right? Like,
okay, we went in and changed the
lyrics. He's like, What if we.
Stop, Kevin. I don't want to.
I don't want to elaborate on that shit.
It's like just Stevie, Stevie, Stevie.
It's 3 a.m.. What?
Like, really? Is it like, what the
f***? What the f*** is the difference?
Like 5 a.m. and 5 p.m.
to Stevie. All right, all right, all
right. So this should happen.
On the hell. Go, go!
This shit happen.
So he just called. He didn't like the
lyrics, You know what I mean?
Like lyrics. Then he called me back.
He was like, okay, yeah, yeah.
Dre, I like the lyrics. Why don't we
get together and just write a song
together? Yeah.
Hi, Stevie. All right.
And. Yeah, I didn't show up.
She said, no, I just can't do it.
What the f*** am I going to do in the
studio with Stevie Wonder?
I mean. I mean, touch the drums.
No. Yeah. Touch the keyboard.
No.
Yeah.
Yeah. What the f***?
Yeah. Nah.
You want to be able to give the best
version, you know?
Yeah, I went that way.
But, Michael, you could have figured it
out with Mike.
Maybe.
Nah, you know what it is?
It's like, do that again, Mike.
Imagine that. Imagine me to tell
Michael Jackson. Nah, Mike, I didn't.
I didn't. I didn't like that. We're
going to need that.
That second harmony one more time.
You imagine that shit right now?
Nah, that's not.
Nah.
I'm sorry, Mike.
Are you singing that or what is that?
No, that's not going to happen.
I know.
So, Mike, say f*** one time.
But these. These mother******* are my
heroes, man. It's like, what the f***
am I going to do in the studio with
Stevie Wonder?
Yeah.
What the f***?
When you. When you explain it, I
understand it. I just thought that,
like, you were like. No, I was curious.
I'm definitely curious.
I'm still curious, but, you know.